it would turn into a shanking match
because shanking match bro bro because
she will twist the tables on me like
isn't this what you wanted this was your
idea this was your
[Music]
idea right guys we're back and you
already know how we like to start the
show flipping F about we go straight
into Nitty Gritty pull those patties to
the side and Dive Right oh I wasn't
ready you Dive Right In come on question
of the week was what's something you
only do when you're home alone oh
interesting very interesting the first
one off the bat admit that I was wrong
and
overreacted wow I admit I was over I was
I was overacted by yourself that
that's jokes that's jokes right bet uh I
cook and watch movies with my boy my
pretend boyfriend having full-blown
conversations too #
delusional that's concerning wow I cook
and watch movies with my pretend
boyfriend that's concerning the cooking
thing is spinning me babe pass me pass
me
the babe I need help babe babe babe oh
my days don't fill up on
bread what about the mains oh that's
God repeatedly look through cupboards
and fridges expecting something
different every time 100% that's me I
think everyone I think every human's
done that bro every human's done that
eat food from the pan in my boxes that
was me in uni uni F yeah those um sofa
cushions they sofa cushions yeah they
got burnt that's why I have to rest my
pot my pot on the Lu yeah tuna pasta
they stra out of pot like aing
facts don't want to I can't I can't be
asked to wash a plate and a pot bro
there's no need there is here it's just
me and a fork that's all I've got I I
miss those days I really do miss those
days so easy facts so easy a lot less
responsibility yeah yeah yeah it was
just calm did I want facts had zero
money to do it but all the free I
did whatever I wanted facts I argue with
Alexa in an in an accent foreign to
mine
a I can imagine that's like five minutes
of entertainment before it get stupid so
pointless this one's disgusting I eat
you're going to hate this one oh go on I
eat grated cheese straight out the bag
that's not a thing that's not a thing
that's I actually saw like three people
write there I was thinking three people
wrote I eat greated cheese yeah that's a
common that's it's way too common yeah
no no no no like 100,000 people viewed
this and replied to this that's too
common three people have right that is
too common damn grated cheese strip
fresh out the
bag why yeah knows why that's I hate
grated cheese do you remember when I
used to have a phobia gry cheese yeah
yeah it's disgusting it's disgusting
that's why you always I never forget you
told me un you always buy a block cheese
yeah till day bro I'm not buying no
grated cheese someone grated that a
machine gr a machine grated it but now I
know also they put agents on it to stop
it stick sticking together which means
it doesn't melt either it doesn't melt
properly so when you have if you put
great cheese on something and put it in
the oven when like it never melts and
blends it's all this liny dirty it's not
good by block cheese people interesting
interesting all right next unbutton my
pants when I want to eat fair damn okay
I get 30 worth of KFC and sit there and
eat it in peace I can't I can't stand it
when she stares at me huh
he what's it called how many pieces 30
worth 30 pound worth yeah not like I'm
talking about fiscal yeah not like
weight like Great British pounds yeah
yeah yeah yeah 30 worth of KFC a lot of
KFC I can't stand when she sits there
and stares at me cuz I'm just a fat mess
I'm a mess I want to eat in peace that
reminds me of like the whale she used to
bring him the bucket of KC back it he'll
back it let me let me just have the skin
let me smell the skin and he start
choking on it yeah oh she was like chew
your food bro he couldn't help it tow
your food M was inhaling the thing he
was massive yeah he was massive wow he
was
massive wow he looked more like a seal
than a whale they should have definitely
called it the seal the seal like
especially when he stood up or try to
stand up you know how seals like they
elong yeah it look like a seal it's
crazy all right what something you do
what something you only do when you're
home alone watch anime undisturbed cuz
when she's around it's always always top
boy
Fair solo anime is VI by the way it's so
binge I binge bro I'm in my own space my
world I am locked in when I watch hours
and hours and hours of it facts bro I
watched the whole season of King as easy
back to back mad back to back mad say
less say it must have been Blissful it
was juicy God all right run up the
stairs on all
fours he do that as a you yeah same
swinging in the
air on all fours you know this chick
wrote I look at my in the
mirror just inspecting making sure
everything's nice down there damn
hell practice my reaction for
when my imaginary boyfriend proposes to
me okay what's going on
on that's
disgusting replay arguments that I know
I should have won highight Is 2020
that's me y I do that that's me too
that's me I do that in the car yeah yeah
yeah cuz you you can't sometimes you
just can't think in the heat yeah in the
heat the moment yeah the the sign upses
are blocked fact facts facts facts fact
I was so jarring yeah and then when I'm
alone I'm like oh why didn't I say that
why didn't I say that disconnected with
this and that point doesn't even make
sense why you know why you're stupid yes
you know why you're dumb bro let me tell
you sit down and let me tell you why
you're actually thick that's me it's so
annoying it's so annoying all right I've
got a few
more what's something you only do when
you're home alone cheat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
obviously wowers jokes this chick wrote
practice butt cheek isolation for
twerking and back shots she's doing
yeah that's jeez yeah that's a Cas study
I have to rate it cheek isolation cheek
the cheek the butt cheek
isolation yeah that's a megallion thing
yeah damn I pick my dog up and sing to
her as if it was my girl times are rough
right now Jes that's Peak that's very
Peak I eat all the snacks I hide from my
children and
husband on my unknown number I call
my friends and tell them I'm their man's
side
[Laughter]
chick
what do you n multiple I call my friends
and tell them I'm their man's s chick
that's nuts you must be
bored does she say haha joking is me or
she just keeps doing
it man side chick bro that's crazy
yeah what a that's crazy
what a I'd masturbate like three
times and later tell my husband I'm not
in the mood that's Peak yeah that's damn
that's Peak I'm not going to lie my
younger years I've done that PE there's
been time there's been times where I'd
have like a girlfriend that's coming
over later but I'm in a house B yeah you
need just I fpp like three times I'm
done for this yeah when she roll I'm
just like obvious not oh I'm red raw
down there how could you even think
about sex at a time like
this I'm done bro she has no idea
yeah she has no idea I've been going to
town all day fapping yeah not today babe
not today all right last one sweeted me
what's something you only do when you're
home alone I play Bleeding Love by Leona
Lewis and sing
bro damn fair play speaking of
singing there is a song I am well and
truly addicted I've listened to this
song 300 times a day for the last six
days it's called treasure in the Hills
by Leon Thomas you man never heard play
this song in full volume obviously I'm
not going to play it now but um you're
welcome treasure on the Hills treasure
in the Hills or I think it's treasure in
the Hills I'm add it to my treasure in
the Hills oo
o uh treasure in the Hills okay um R&B
type R&B Indie type John okay bro okay
it's juicy okay say it's juicy let me
add it to add to Q yeah I've been
screaming out the top of my lungs say um
what do I do when my okay when I'm and
the house alone fap like a man possessed
facts who doesn't um I do the argumen
thing facts I win arguments by myselfs I
win arguments by myself I practice dance
moves oh I think that's my ADHD I do
that regardless if you're not if you're
not alone or not no alone or not I do
that regardless like I could be going
from the sofa to the toilet I'd stand up
walk a few steps and M Rock for no
reason fa the other day I went from the
oven to the fridge and I did you know
this one I can't do that to save my life
I know exactly what you're talking about
I've been practicing can't do that to my
life secr you have to start slow oh yeah
you have to start really really
like yeah I've been practic in that
from fridge to oven from oven to
fridge but I can't do I can do right
foot step back left foot wiggle I can't
do the vice verse I just can't do it but
step back left foot
wiggle I'm not amb beex like that I
can't do the other side bro but the
flooring means everything yeah of course
of course wow I tried to do it on some
sticky floor the other day I need to
twist my ankle it's crazy but yeah
that's I practice dance
moves and I um I Crump a lot
when I about myself I Crump a lot um and
then that's do you remember
titing Jesus yeah yeah finger the finger
yeah yeah that was mad I I had a routine
down when I was like finger yeah
remember yeah yeah yeah I had this this
that was the one
yeah you has a bre it back
in
that's
hilarious that's hilarious that's
embarrassing yeah I had that down bro
had like an 11c routine yeah I was
trying to impress
everyone I was n on crosses on my I
remember bro wow wow gas that's so
pathetic um yeah boy uhing wow if the
right song comes on it's long just all
you need is one foot stump and it sends
shock waves your whole body it just
sends shock waves and you can't stop bro
your whole body is jok W sometimes I
love being alone sometimes I love being
alone you just do wild dumb
stupid I remember back in uni I
used to just relax my hair cuz it was
Sunday do you remember I used to just
relax the out of my hair cuz it
made my wavy I actually don't
remember do you don't remember I used to
relax the out of my head oh swear
yeah it used to make my wavy as
Fair makes sense it was nuts fair
fair fair fair anyway one time I got so
bored I relaxed it and trying to doal
com over thing no you never I got I
don't understand bored no you never uni
yeah I had a part in here and combed
like this side this side and then this
side down there yeah I look like I'm
look like Malcolm
[Laughter]
X the funny thing is because I know you
didn't have a beard in uni I could see
it bro baby face com Mal
X you don't understand how funny that is
bro that visual all you need are
circular glasses and it's a
wrap that's too funny I don't M
yeah Jesus I was bored yeah that's
so funny um what do I do when I'm home
alone I apart from the usual like
fapping or whatever I just bored out my
mind I lay on the sofa and like when I'm
eating snacks I'm at my worst yeah I'm
like a pig eating on the sofa alone
because obviously I got a beard it
popcorn Skittles them things falls into
my beard Falls or it falls here I can
see that but no one can see it when it
falls on your chest or yeah and it just
rolls down your stomach you're like oh
yeah I'm an animal bro I'm an actual
animal I've had sessions snack sessions
where I've just been going going going
going bro daddy will stand up and there
just smoo under my ass
oh swear like melted chocolate and Crums
and smoed jelly beans under my ass and
I'm like how what happened yeah yeah
yeah how did we get here what happened
it rolled all down me and I just I just
wiggled in it I'm sick oh it is
embarrassing when no one can see this
it's embarrassing head it's hell in the
comments Below guys let us know what you
guys do at home when you're alone yeah
we'll be doing at Home Alone um but
anyway guys welcome back um thank you
for joining us today if you know what's
good for you head on over to to
patreon.com and gigs and catch up
on three four nearly years worth of
content weekly weekly juicy juicy
content let us know what you think3 a
month 10 a day run the P to sng and
contribute pay dividends and contribute
to your boys so we your daddies can live
successfully facts live by KC through
USS via ego patreon facts if you're
watching on YouTube please subscribe to
the channel facts CH the s in the
comments like the video you like the
video and if you an audio listener and
you like the smooth mellow tones of your
boys please leave a nice review it means
a lot it helps grow the channel it's
juicy to
see and it's a good deed for the day
facts so please do and do that and our
beloved remky is not in the building um
today he's galivan in on holiday so
there will be no top five today unfor
guys sorry someone dm' me the other day
and they were like James I love you man
but when are you going to tell REM he's
got a fan club of of things what and I
was like what am what why is this why is
this responsibility falling on me f what
REM reads plenty of comments by damn
self why do I need to stop reming his
tracks and tell him that's right tell
him your F why you dming me fact I I
hate when I get DMS and like oh tell
James this this this like what are we
talking about here here what we actually
talking about imagine as I get to say
tell Fe to stop ignoring me tell Fe to
stop ignoring me I know he's with you
them ones are the worst I know he's with
you tell just start ignoring me
Jo I know he's with you oh you like have
audacity and I don't even know the word
g at the same time it's crazy bro
audacity and G is exactly right oh God
couldn't believe it I know he's next to
you yeah bro I know he's there tell him
stop ignoring me that's I don't
know you bro yeah it's it's crazy anyway
it's it is crazy right I'm going to kick
us off with a thread all right hit me if
you don't mind I never and believe it or
not this thread was sent into me by our
lovely manager oh let's go yeah man
let's go Tyler thread is called boy math
ah I knew it was going to be that you
got it I've got something similar and
I'm Yeah Boy math might have to be a
running theme made me laugh
right this is so factual bro boy math is
wanting zero kids but having zero
condoms on
hand 100% that's so factual it's
unbelievable that's why pull out game
exists facts and sometimes it doesn't
exist and I still don't want to use I
still don't want that
you oh God that's facts boy H boy math
is how 5' 10 measures 6
foot yeah that's boy math to be first
yeah we haven't got choice though yeah
we have that's involuntary boy M you
leave us no choice I've never once said
I was 6 foot I wouldn't dare yeah
because I'm not daddy's too broad you
know what I mean I'm too broad and too
thick and um I don't look 6 foot okay
even if I was six foot people would
challenge me okay so I would never in a
million years so disrespectful that's so
disrespectful you are so dis how many
people when we post a picture together
say there's no way James is taller than
3 every single time they see it they're
like like this is lens magic yeah yeah
yeah yeah like this he's he's a he's a
bottom boy yeah he's a liar in a bottom
yeah he's a liar in his a bottom boy get
off your
toes right I couldn't I could never ever
see a picture and find you on your tippy
toes I don't think you understand what
that would do to my nature you I'll be
so Shell Shocked all I'm going to say is
don't be if you see a picture of me on
my tippy toes don't be Shell Shocked cuz
sometimes I don't like I haven't got a
choice I've never I don't think I've
actually done it in a picture I
guarantee you I've never done it in a
picture but I have definitely stood on
my tiptoes with in front of a bud in
heels who's taller or at least eye level
yeah I've leave her like lent on a bar
or something yeah yeah I and I don't I
don't know what my next steps are yeah
cuz if she if she wants to vacate the
the area I don't know what to do yeah
it's a heel thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's disgusting um me boy math is
thinking the answer to did you come is
yes I need a running tally of how many
times I've been lied to because in my
head is
zero you know what I mean in my reality
is zero yeah and you can't face the real
reality yeah especially in the moment
because I'm I'm recollecting there's
been times where because the girls I've
been with in the past have actually been
like fairly open like I know you didn't
not let's not play games well to be fair
if I I I know you did nut so we never
have to have a conversation yeah that's
what I'm saying yeah there was no moment
in there where we could be confused
about whether United or not yeah facts
facts facts there's never that facts but
there has been definite occasions in my
life not many couple where we're
specifically aiming for
snut and I'm like we've been going and
she's locked in locked in and we're
going going going going going and she's
in the general area she's in a penny box
mhm and she's she's trying to cook and
I'm like I'm six Strokes out yeah it's
now or never and then she nuts and I'm a
bit like did you though yeah I'm not so
sure it was all a bit too convenient cuz
I had no choice yeah yeah and you might
picked up on it and thought charging it
yeah char in it we're faking it today
yeah I can think of like two
occasions where I thought H
suspicious yeah yeah I want to say
it's happened to me but for the life of
me I can't recall of a recent incident
or one that like sticks out but for sure
I I it's not something I even want to
get my brain to dive into but I know
have faked it before you just
know you know you know you just know
yeah you know I just but ignorance is
bliss facts that's why I don't want my
brain to digest such information I don't
need my brain to digest that information
but I know have faked it before
so it just is what it is I've never
faked it I faked it I can't I just don't
see how you can fake I just stop I just
say I can't come yeah can't fake nut
yeah that's what I'm saying I don't want
to do that so I just I faked it like two
three times where I'm just like what
inside are you pulling out um if you're
okay I was going to say if you're
pulling out how you but no I've pulled
out before as well actually and then how
are you faking it I just not into my
hand
apparently jokes and if you're inside
surely she can feel that you've not Ned
it's not up to me fair cuz it's it's one
it's a power play cuz it's like are you
going to confront me I didn't think so
are you going to confront me about this
cuz now you're embarrassing both of us
damn so it's evil I tell the truth and
you're the only one embarrassed or Let
Me Lie and if you stay silent no one's
embarrassed or if you confront me we're
both embarrassed so let's just leave
it um but yeah I faked it
like more probably more than like two
three times I don't think I've ever
faked it where like yeah I just couldn't
come and then my my mind was like bro
this ain't happening and then I'm
thinking my now cuz I've acknowledged
it's not happening I'm losing wood at a
a drastic rate yeah so I need to I need
to rain it in now I need to pull the
plug on this because in my head it's a
better option to fake it than it is for
me cuz I'm not now flipping the
narrative that I can't keep a hard dick
that's not the narrative we're going
with okay okay okay okay so it's like I
either pretend to not yeah and hope for
the best M or I tell her I can't n break
her heart insecurity level goes through
the roof or I just let my go soft
and she thinks daddy can't keep a hard
dick and that's the option we're
definitely not going for so I always end
up pretending okay fair enough makes
sense yeah makes sense but yeah you're a
Savage I'm not surprised you just say I
canot
yeah yeah you're you're you're a real
one to be fair um all right boy math is
putting on a jersey with another grown
man's name on it every Sunday while
mocking while mocking The
Beehive Fair wow wow Fair wow unlocked
Fair wow I remember when I was um young
like 11 M my
background was t pack on my phone my
screen saver on my phone okay okay okay
okay and my uncle I was at my uncle's
house I'm already sweeted know why two
pack yeah yeah yeah yeah two pack there
was a marijuana leaf behind
him some of the choices of words you use
bro bro it was tup pack marijuana leave
behind
him and obviously just said like thug
life under or something like that I was
gassed I was I thought I was road yeah I
was at my uncle's house in France and he
saw it and he said and obviously two
stays topless yeah and he said why have
you got a man a grown man's breast on
your phone yeah I was like that's do
pack man come
on I'm not King but to push me you know
what it is man yeah he said that's a
naked man on your
phone I said yo yo yo no no no no no
it's not uncle uncle uncle stop stop he
said brother as a naked man on your
phone what are you doing I was like it's
two B cuz I don't care who it is get
this man's breast off your phone your
phone oh wow I found you s like an adult
yeah I said
wow wow he SP fact fact I said there's a
naked man on your phone your world
changed your world changed all of a
sudden the weed didn't make a difference
the Marana Leaf is the funniest bar and
I don't know why oh Bro it's so
funny boy boy MAF is them wanting a
prenup and they only make
45k damn that's tough awesome boy MAF is
opening up your marriage so you can
around then get mad because your wife is
getting slammed while you severely
overestimate your market
value that's every man that's ever
lived the only Dons that are
successfully doing up open relationship
are like just celebrities oh facts facts
like top tier one celebrities yeah yeah
NFL player yeah yeah yeah that's
otherwise what we what we playing at
facts facts your wife's getting ran
through the thought of that yeah bro I'm
telling you rocks me to my yeah yeah
yeah I'm telling you there is nothing I
could do like to like to to mitigate the
pain that would semi Drew I just
couldn't obviously I spoke it spoke
about it bare times before um
what's his name Aubrey Marcus I think
it's Aubrey Marcus head of uh onit
supplements or whatever okay on it
nutrition I can't remember what they're
called okay um yeah he tells a story on
a podcast about how he was in an open
relationship and his wife the first time
his wife stepped out to get clapped or
his girlfriend or whatever said he spent
the whole night crying and throwing up
oh yeah yeah I think I remember the
story I can't remember his name crying
and throwing up I don't think you
understand what I'm saying crying is a
big man you know crying
and throwing up while his girl was out
getting completely smacked to
Pieces
are you me deep in what I'm saying
I can't I can't live through that
yeah man them think so selfishly when
they free up yeah the open relationship
relationship yeah yeah yeah because
there's there's just not a reality where
it works for me yeah yeah facts I can't
know this information I can never know
this information
crying and throwing up crying and
throwing up I'd have to change I'd have
to change the locks she can't come back
to yeah yeah you can't come back cuz I
can't see you Rosy
cheek happy disheveled Rosy Cheeks facts
hairold m fight different scent or fresh
fragrance cuz she's been mered she had a
shower God she clear She's Fresh you
also can't come in and come straight in
the
shower shower his actually don't because
if he's got different shower gel I'm
just going to with the
just don't yeah yeah don't don't come
back honestly don't come back don't ever
ever come backu yeah that will rock me
to my core you're going to come in and
kiss me and say you love me you don't
you don't love me yeah yeah you love the
dick you just got facts you loved that
yeah yeah didn't you you loved that it
would turn into a shanking match because
shanking match bro bro because she will
twist the tables on me she like isn't
this what you wanted this was your this
was your idea yeah and I haven't
at all I know whose idea it was fact my
DM's been quiet since since I've said
this out loud said God says yes since he
said yes nothing's been
fruitful nothing's been fruitful I don't
want you out in the streets anymore
close the whole
relationship oh it's not been fruitful
nothing's been fruitful for
me bro it's impossible oh God stab
myself bro it will turn into a shanking
w yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah bro she'll F she'll come home to
find me doing the wildest bro just
repainting walls bro cuz I need to get
my mind I'm redecorating because love
doesn't live here facts I need something
new to look at oh God Jesus Christ boy
math is having a 70in TV but no dining
table
wow I'm not even joking my yard came
with a dining table if it didn't I
promise you I'm not buying one
and I'll buy the biggest TV I can find
bro facts mine every yard I've moved
into has come with a dining table and my
TV is
massive that's
hilarious that is hilarious wow um boy
math is Raising um three pitbulls
instead of one child
facts
facts go boy math is being afraid of
gold diggers when you don't have a
headboard a headboard fan listen to me
listen to me bro in our third yard in
uni I didn't have a headboard and a
was on
Wheels every time every time I had a
Ting over and would want to watch a
movie I would prop the pillow up against
this plastered wall I'd lean and
the tting would slide down oh no I never
felt so broke oh no that's embarrassing
bro that is embarrassing I've never felt
so broke I'm sorry G the thing would
slide every time I'm sorry G and my
pillow would fall behind the bed so I
have to oh bro the whole thing was I
hated it that Absol BS sorry G
oh God right that's me all right boy MAF
is having like four baby mam but only
caring for the child whose Mama whose
mama you with but only caring for the
child whose mama you with yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah makes sense it does
make sense after a
while boy math man who struggles to
please one girlfriend but once a
threesome oo okay
okay boy math is getting your
heartbroken once in grade school then
seeking revenge on every girl you date
afterwards damn wow okay okay all right
bet Yeah Boy MAF is interesting I'm
trying to get a girl MAF one going yeah
there was a bit of both in here but I'm
going save that for next week all right
bet that's juicy I'm here for it is this
this is the new team this could be the
new boy say all right bet okay I'm going
to take a real real quick break and
today I'm speaking specifically to the
lovely ladies in the audience okay
listen close fresh ball fall is right
around the corner and you know what that
means it means cozy sweaters it means
pumpkin spice and of course getting your
man's full foliage all groined up with
manscape while nature takes care
of the leaves we're here to make sure
your man's nether region is leafree and
ready for sweat a weather let's go give
the gift of manscape to your special guy
for cuffing season and make sure he's
feeling as fresh as that crisp autumn
air now you're wondering how do I get
involved what do I need to do daddy
instruct me right shut up head over to
manscape.com and use the code sng Sierra
November golf going to give you a very
generous 20% off and free shipping go
immediately and then return back here
let's get back to the episode facts say
less cool so I'm here to talk about the
highly requested Married at First Sight
oh yeah UK version mhm mhm let me set
for this people yeah people been
reaching out telling me to watch this
this thing and I've got stuff to say so
I Stay up late last night I'm super
tired today cuz I stayed up late last
night watching this foolishness yeah
I've not even got through all the
weddings yet so obviously we all know
the premise MH two people getting
married they've never met before MH and
they just want to see how it patterns
right so the running theme this season
bro is
insecurity okay that's all I'm saying
that's all I'm hearing the running theme
this year is insecurity so far so I'm on
like episode three or four okay and the
running theme is insecurity bro okay no
one knows who fancies who oh okay no one
knows bro I'm looking at the the cast
now yeah yeah yeah no one knows who
fancy who so I'm going to focus on three
couples today mhm one so there's a chick
on here called Jay Jay has one
arm fam it's important to the story Jay
has one arm I'm looking at her right now
and she was
shook that Donnie was not going to check
for her cuz of his arm m she was
terrified and fair play to her broag
Fair play to her she was
stressed The Narrative about the fear of
rejection because of this arm bro even
her like sister and her Breen she was
she was trying to like she was back like
uh back in her dressing room trying to
like rationalize the thing yeah I'll be
like ah well maybe he like he won't
notice the sister jumped J he's going to
notice he's going to notice get
out of your head now that's you're
hoping for get it out of your head now
the first thing he's going to no bro
it's the first thing he's going to see
yeah so just leave that I know you want
to get comfortable yeah but drop that
illusion yeah let's think better tactics
than that so anyway she pulled up her
man's called Luke MH he's cool sales guy
Essex guy bear Essex mhm he's down for
her okay down for her and he kept like
insisting how banging she is to him okay
reassuring her reassuring and she at
first Ro she just wasn't having it she
literally wasn't having it and then
every time he' be like she's banging
she's banging she's exactly what I asked
for she's banging she's banging and then
everyone be like what about the arm I
don't give a about the arm she's
banging she's banging well other couples
is like why going for the arm not the
couples now I was going to say like her
sister and like her family and people
and like around like doesn't it bother
you doesn't bother you and even her like
doesn't it bother you he I don't give a
he's like I'm not going to lie when
you B down the thing I said ra yeah I
was shocked yeah and he said who
wouldn't be yeah yeah facts the first
time you can't anticipate that but it
doesn't I don't care yeah so they went
on the
honeymoon clapped and after all of this
fluers before they clapped they went on
like a little cocktail thing when I say
this brother was
flirting
flirting bro what she on it she she
seemed like she just didn't believe him
that's mad in security I yeah she just
seemed like then like you could she was
feeling like he's just begging it now
he's begging it but when say Donnie was
flirting and I can see why because you
forget that they know they're in front
of
cameras because we can't see the cameras
we just think oh natural but they're in
front of the cameras so you could tell
she might be thinking like he's
literally playing up for the cameras
okay and then fam soon as he went back
to the room my Donnie clapped damn
clapped the next morning she was like oh
he fances me oh say less oh he fances me
say less I'm gassed say less gang gang G
it was g g g it was g g next level of
insecurity Thomas is incure so now we're
flipping on the guy Thomas is insecure
bro so he married rosin he's a posh you
okay very Posh you so they got married
and he's adamant no one fances him let
alone like his wife no one fances him MH
so he was saying about how his ex
bullied the out of him oh like she
would like he'd be driving and she'd
take a picture of like a side profile
and she' be like big man you need a nose
drop come
on the love of my life
oh and he was going on about like H bro
like she would tell me I'm too ugly I'm
too skinny I'm too hairy I'm too this
and he just doesn't trust chicks anymore
bro bro he just doesn't trust them
yeah so he gets married to her obviously
it's awkward it's always awkward and
then on their honeymoon she's like I'm
not trying to push you but like I need
something I need like let's just try
cuddles I said let's not force it calm
fam he said let's calm down let's not
force it cuddles fam she's like big man
it can be a friendly cuddle if you want
just cuddle I need I need s SK yeah I
need skin tactile and he's said I said
Roslin I'm not going to lie to you I'm
not just out here cuddling strangers she
says strangers we're wife
I hate that they use that bar your wife
we just got married we fact four hours
ago bro um J I'm calling strangers and
then she kept pushing it kept pushing it
kept pushing it and then she was like
big man I'm not lying to you anymore and
it's sat a cuddle bro let's just try a
cuddle and he was like I'm not going to
lie you does not give me the impression
that you fancy me and she was like w
and he was like like I need like I have
mad insecurity about this kind of stuff
and I just don't deem myself fanciable
okay so unless you're giving me an
example that you fancy me I'm just not
going to think that you fancy me and she
said big man out of two of us who's
moving to who I've been begging you for
a little bit of contact for 3 days now
and you have the audacity to tell me
that you don't think I've answer you
yeah that I'm going to need a bit of
something yeah I'm begging you for
anything yeah and then now you're and
your answer to that is like you don't
think I answer you are you cracked and
he said fam he said raw boy math raw he
said raw facts M he said it's actually
fact you have been making
me he said you know what wow you
actually have bit Begg of
me I didn't deep it I just think you
didn't fancy me she said wow this guy's
an idiot he's a child child is the word
that's exactly thought I've married a
child I've married a child yeah yeah
yeah he doesn't get it he said
all right cuddles are on cuddles are up
yeah um cool so that's that one cool
who's giving me the insecurities next oh
my God okay this is an interesting run
right so next we've got
Nathaniel
and Ella I was waiting for you to say
Ella I saw
murmurs but I saw murmurs this the first
time I've seen a picture yeah m i saw
murmurs right so Nathaniel and
Ella interesting case do you know what's
interesting it's actually interesting so
I'm not up to date okay so I didn't deep
this just slight pausing from the from
the con uh from the content for a while
and let's get personal MH this whole
like situation that we're in now where
the show is growing and all this kind of
stuff um and people specifically look
out for our commentary on certain things
okay is scary okay
because things are happening now where
like Clips are taken where like we're
talking about something or someone and
then it gets back to them like someone
told me that like Central C had seen the
video about me talking about I got
shamed by Central SE in the in Village
or whatever it was and then like other
people are like oh this person's seen
this and like I might say something we
spoke about the gym shark event and then
like someone's clipping it and sending
it to the bre and all this kind of stuff
and it's going around it's doing the
rounds and all this kind of stuff and
I'm like ra like you stuff and people
actually it gets back to the person
you're talking about um the funny thing
about this one is I only watched it last
night mhm and as I'm watching it I'm
looking at the the cast and the couples
and all that stuff and I'm thinking this
Neel bre looks familiar he's in our dmms
right now oh really he's been in our DMS
for a day or two okay and I haven't
opened it yeah and there's like I went
on I was like I swear down went in the
DMS and he's in our DMS and he's posted
like an article from the mirror or
something like that and I didn't want
any spoilers so I just assumed it was
about the show yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
didn't open it so I was like let me
catch up and then I'll open this thing
cuz I'll be livid if I open it and it's
a spoiler that I haven't seen yet yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I was thinking
ra like donn's preempting that we're
going to talk about it I haven't even
seen it yeah yeah wow johny's in the DM
preempting oh wow that we're going to
talk about his stuff wow and I was like
damn that's that's a lot that's a lot I
felt pressure yeah that's a lot I felt
pressure I imagine I felt pressure I was
like ra okay I can't just say whatever I
want now that's a lot Daddy's got to get
that tongue under W pause pause indeed
right a lot anyway yeah interesting
Nathaniel and Ella so Nathaniel mix Ray
geiza from Birmingham he sounds like
he's from Birmingham um no he's from
Manny it's from Manny according to this
he does not sound like he's fromone he's
from money that's surprising to me he
sounds brammy as anyway Nathaniel
and Ella yeah
so I'm not going to lie yeah I feel like
Nathaniel's cooking up a bit of drama on
purpose okay it's interesting let me
give you the back story of what I've
seen so far I don't know what article is
posted to me I don't know what's going
on and I've heard the spoilers on Tik
Tok and I've been staying away from it
I'll catch up tonight but anyway from
what I've seen so far weding B in so ell
trans
mhm um and when I say in fam you would
not guess in certain she said that
there's um she's like it's actually
dread her story was actually dread she
was saying that like how how she was
like one of the highest percentage
people swiped on um Tinder like like
right on Tinder right is the right one
right right yeah yeah yeah yeah right is
right right is right is right is right
left is wrong yeah yeah yeah yeah left
you get left right right all right come
on so she was like high percentage of
people Swip right Swip right swi right
and and she was saying that she was
linking guys all the time and then like
someone finds out she's trans and be
like charging it not on it others would
uh find out your trans and be like I'm
down but shut the up
yeah that's exactly the bar I'm down but
this stays between us so she was like
this is long my whole life is long yeah
so when
um when they sat down for the team
um no sorry when they got married he was
all over her Gass this that you're
paying this this this this and this now
I feel that both of them are playing a
secret little game okay because they
said on there already The Producers or
the commentator or whatever the narrator
was like ah
Nathaniel has been informed he doesn't
know anything else about his wife mhm
but he's been informed that she's trans
prior to the marriage prior to the
marriage doesn't know anything else
about her but he has been informed that
she's trans and he was down cuz he's
pansexual so basically he said I like
boys I like girls I like anyone who
makes me feel like I'm attracted to you
so like looks calm okay being pretty
handsome whatever calm it's all about
how you make me feel okay it's an
interesting matchup yeah fact very
interesting match up okay so he' already
been told that she was trans mhm so when
she met him on the day and there was a
couple of her examples where she was
doing too much so on the bachelorette
party on the Hindu whatever mhm someone
mentioned family MH and she was like oh
my God don't get me started on family
and talk about how much like her mom and
dad love her and her Nan and all these
kind of things but when I say she wasn't
crying but she had the tissue and she
was me I didn't see a tear bro she was
like making up a big big drama I didn't
see a tear and I was like H interesting
SS M interesting so fast forward wedding
day he's all over her their lips in gang
gang gang I'm not going to say I'm going
to lie she said a b she said a bar she
said a bar I was like oo I when they do
the vows yeah every all the all the um
ministers have been like ah you can now
like kiss your husband kiss your bride
or just give him a peck on the cheek cuz
obviously you don't know each other
everyone's else like everyone everyone
else was like all the other couples like
pick on the cheek or do you want to do
you want a lips or just pick on the
cheek and a lot of them were like yeah
pick on the cheek or like n give me a
little kiss fam they said kiss or Peck
in the cheek and the family was like up
to you she said what do you think fam
she said what do you think they
lips they lips I said ra they're banging
tonight they're banging tonight say
anyway so fast forward to the
honeymoon no no no no sorry sorry sorry
sorry so they're there and she said I'm
enjoying myself but I have to sit him
down and tell him the truth she sits him
down again starts crying and she's like
I have to tell you tears or no tears a
little bit of Tears okay little bit she
starts crying getting flustered he's
like what's going on he looks concerned
and she's like oh God I have to get it
out I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm and he's
like she's like I'm trans and he was
like I know he didn't say I know but I
think I I I was waiting for him to be
like yeah I know but he might have
thought like oh maybe the producers want
me to play like I didn't know but we
already knew that he knew she's like I'm
trans and he was like it's calm she was
like really and he's like it's calm and
then I was
thinking what is this what's this what's
this fake drama was it shown like was it
shown to you prior that he knew that she
was trans PRI to the marriage was it
shown to the public that's what I'm
saying the narrator said it he bought
both their pictures up and was like
Nathaniel under Ella's consent
Nathaniel's been told that she's trans
so we know that he knows and we know
that she knows that he knows so w Guan
fam that's what I'm saying I was like
what's this play play stuff okay makes
sense so I was like interesting let's
dive in yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they go
on their honeymoon to Mexico I assumed
they've been banging the whole time oh
that's why that's why after that that
wedding day lips she was like bro he
hasn't touched me since we got
here all this wedding Vibes has gone
down and I need to know W Guan so she
pulled him to the side and was like
brother do you fancy me or not and he
was like look I told you it's all about
how people make me feel yada y y like I
want to be your friend first before I
get sexually involved and all that stuff
she was like but I'm asking you do you
think I'm paying or not okay and he was
like paying is paying is paying mhm I
don't even have I like you as a person
MH and that's what matters to me like
before I bang you I have to like you as
a human being okay and she was like well
why are you not thinking you like me as
a human being and he said Fam I'm not
going to lie to you
every time we're by ourselves you're
quiet you're confiding you're doing all
this stuff as soon as D's are in here
you're shouting you're dramatic you're
crying you're this and he's like I'm not
here for it she's two different people
okay she said swear I'm two different
people big man you're a showman he said
what yeah she said you're a
showman okay and he was like you're
tapped he was like fam was like don't
you dare don't you dare she's like
you're a showman brother I'm calling how
it is give reasons or she just saying
stuff she said she said if you think I'm
playing for the cameras you're
completely different he I given you
everything I've given you everything
don't you dare yeah yeah yeah yeah she
said I'm calling how I see it he said
this you're twisting for these
man again you're a liar walked into the
room she said you're a prick and
he's he screamed from the bedroom don't
you dare don't you D Master said don't
belittle yourself like that oh raw I
said raw the whole thing was raw ra so
there a little bit of drama going on
between them two and I don't understand
and also she tried to pull him to the
side the next day and was like look I'm
sorry I called you prick I'm sorry I'm
all this and he kind of exasperated the
situation from jump like say he's still
livid which some people are but again I
was thinking H how real is this so we're
going to put a pin in Nathaniel Ella
okay and we stood her up for the final
dinner oh he stood her the up oh ra
yeah it was mad oh right okay yeah yeah
yeah she was there chilling by herself
cleavage ah damn she was wearing one of
them long shirts nothing else it was
crazy um just left her there damn so
yeah I'm intrigued I was I was expecting
more from them considering you told me
from the jump cuz I already knew she was
trans before you said that cuzz that was
one of the things I was like oh
this is what I've heard about um but
when you told me he was pansexual I was
thinking oh this could bang oh yeah so
that was I this was a you thought they
were trying to trick yeah no I'm saying
this whole story that you just said is a
complete 18 to what I thought was going
to be like between them murmurs you
thought they were just going to tricker
unsuspecting breath yeah fam because
obviously I only saw that um apparently
in this new cast that there's going to
be a transom oh okay but and that's all
think raw how are they going to like
pattern this cuz it's called Married at
First Sight you know what I mean how
going to it so yeah yeah yeah it's mad
uh next couple cuz I still haven't done
all the weddings yet yeah Okay cool so
next one I'm a quick one mhm Arthur and
Laura MH ARA's polish Laura came in and
said I want a Chelsea boy I want Posh
money MH and that's what I'm here
for arur is a tennis coach originally
from Poland good good good good English
but like not a Chelsea boy okay
got his vows from the internet okay she
was livid okay she was livid bet but
then again what do you write for Mar
fact he was like I don't know what to I
don't know you at the end of the thing
he read out to his boys like these are
the vows and at the end it said like you
are my everything I love you his brother
said get that out there now yeah get
that out there he's like no no no no
like do you not think that's right like
I believe in love at first sight he was
like well how about this if you look at
her and you love her at first sight then
say I love you if you don't don't say I
love you let just that bit out he was
like all right say l say l say less he's
reading it reading it reading it found
he got to the end he looked at her he
looked at his brother and said I love
you he
said he looked at her looked at his
brother and was like I love you his
brother's brother when he said I love
you she
said she said what anyway so they've
been going going G she found out about
the internet thing okay so her
bridesmaid's tadle tailed on him and
said I've just heard he got his thing
from the internet she said say less
she's this how you know women secretly
evil she waited all the way to their
honeymoon to bring it up to bring it up
they were having a bath together and
then she did the whole Long window she
didn't come out and be like look this is
what I heard is it true or not she did
the whole like it's just
funny that your vows they just seem so
heartfelt um were they heartfelt oh God
and was like yeah and she was
like it's just it's just really weird we
because like one would like one could
potentially say that you got them from
the internet with this the internet yeah
yeah
yeah when I say he reached for champagne
he could have be
B I said he charges yeah I did still and
then they had a little she was like big
man I'm not on that I'm not on that and
you're a liar she exasperated the thing
so anyway she wasn't feeling him wasn't
feeling him wasn't feeling him she's
like this is guy is not for me bro he's
not what I asked for he doesn't look
like what I want he doesn't act like
what I want and he's doing things like
getting like getting stuff from the
Internet it's all crazy I'm not on it
they had a tennis caught on their thing
so he said ah we're going to go play
some tennis today when she saw him play
tennis yeah fam yeah she bit it yeah she
likes the sports B she said
watching a man do his good at sexy bet
sexy tables of turn let's go and she's
got one of them kind of like I can't
explain it she's kind of sexy okay she's
kind of bad okay I'm not going to lie
yeah she's kind of bad okay say less and
then yeah they got back that night he
gave her a massage stayed exclusively on
the cheeks it was juicy so now he's one
over oh and at the last dinner he said I
know you were really pissed off I'm
trying my best to be like an authentic
person yada yada y she was like cool
cool cool he's like so I woke he's like
I woke up this morning I thought what
would make Laura happy like what would
actually make her happy she was like
cool what did you come up with I rewrote
those vows
fam she said swear it was G okay F had
and the vows were lit okay so then man
yeah we're going to see stuff say we're
going to see stuff I can't wait okay say
less right and last one I'm going to
stop on mhm is
Jor yeah I saw that name I was thinking
why is it called fren French you oh Jor
and Peggy Peggy let me find Peggy all
right I'm listening though when I say
Peggy and her family are manipulators oh
so this is where we started off yeah
yeah George came in immediate waste man
immediate waste man bro he came in and
was like bro listen yeah I'm tired of
this Playboy Bachelor lovey living life
large lifestyle I'm ready to
settle down like I he's basically moving
like I've just been clapping too many
cheeks too regular and I can't find love
m i I got money and I've got Charisma
and I'm banging let me provide for you
yeah yeah yeah yeah run me a wife
because too many the streets want me too
bad and everyone's like shut up bro yeah
and then they're all talking like oh his
boys are all talking like what kind of
wife do you want and man just said
fam tits I'm looking for tits he said
Matt said if she's part of the ity Bitty
Titty Committee I don't think this is
going to
pattern wow f
M wow I said raw you're a national
television live TV what are you doing my
guy wow yeah yeah if she's part of the
itty bitty TTY committee I don't want
none of that yeah I don't want a piece
of it damn so they get married she's
walking down the aisle Donnie turns
around his face lights up and then they
pull him aside afterwards after he said
the vows he's like good Lord like you're
stunning you're Divine you're everything
and then got a French ACC
but he spits French when he wants he's
got completely English accent okay so
they said the producer like what do you
think what do you think I
said that's oo wow good wow piece of
yeah this is a game yeah it's all a
game it's all a game bro so
anyway we leave that he goes back and
the sister P her sister pulls him to the
side he like right that's my little
sister like I don't know you from Adam
like I need to find out some stuff like
let me talk
she led him into a false insecurity and
just shank and twisted him oh fam he's
sitting there talking to her like yeah
yeah yeah yeah one of his boys walks
past and he goes he goes like that to
one of his boys be in mind this is
wedding day it's a party yeah he goes
out to one of Bo she was like well
that's a bad start don't be winking at
other people when I'm talking to you pay
attention to me he said ra he said
what's all this hity no no I wouldn't
this is wedding day I can't have that
kind of chat yeah yeah yeah this my
wedding day was all this hostility yeah
so he was like all right bet like go
what do you want to say so she's like I
want to make sure that like you're
comfortable like this is good for her
like I'm so protective of her like what
are you going to do for her and he's
like we're going to have like this is
the start of an amazing adventure like
we're going to have a great time and she
was like but it's not about a great time
though is it this is marriage it's not
all about having a great time he said
bro bro chill this is day what's all
this stuff man I'm saying this is the
beginning of a great adventure it's our
life it's going to be fun I know it's
not all about fun but the first thing
out my mouth is yeah we're going to have
some fun she said all right bet scenario
you've never met her before obviously do
you think she's good looking he's like I
think she's stunning she said bet so
what happens tonight first night of your
marriage what happens man said she takes
the lead what like I'm not going to
pressure her I'm not going to recommend
I'm not going to suggest she takes the
lead so like what that's my sister it's
your you don't know her so what like if
she's on it you're just going to do it
and I said she takes the lead bro she's
an adult she's 32 she's an adult she's
an adult bro she takes the lead that's
what I'm saying and he was like n she
was like nah n n n n n n n n I'm done
with this she walked off back to the
camera and said I hate I don't like this
guy bro I'm not on it the sister
fam the sister the sister and
I saw a spoiler that I'm living about
Peggy
too she tricked Donnie as well with the
same tactics they're on a honeymoon now
and she said oh when a lot of people
look at me they assume that I do like
basically like adult content okay and
they always think like I can do adult
content I can make loads of money from
doing adult
content um like if I said I wanted to do
adult content with like what would you
say and man said I think you should do
whatever makes you happy like she said
would you have a problem he's said I
would have a problem with that if you
want to do that then you should do it
she said
raw
raw my husband you know saying that I
should basically do porn oh my God is
that what you're telling me said don't
loow me into this false sense security
we having an honest conversation honest
conversation I'm just he said I just
want you to do whatever makes you happy
that's what I'm trying to say she said
nah brother nah brother there's no way
there's no way I've gone on this journey
like left my family and friends for you
to be telling me that you're cool we've
been posted up nude online like what is
that bro what is that my he said I just
want you to do what you want bro she was
like what I want to do is get the
out of here and I said n I'm not I'm not
dealing with stuff like that I look at I
look at all the producers cameras roll
my eyes yeah yeah I'd roll my eyes i'
have to charge the thing from there fact
but anyway I'm going to pause it there
I've been chatting long enough it's
getting juicy it sounds like sket I'm
not going to Li I'm locked in I'm inrig
that's one of your like five couples out
of how many 10 there's a lot I'm locked
in there's a lot to come I'm locked in
all right cool cool cool all right cool
cool cool cool cool
so you might already know um I've taken
a break on just talking about United
clearly cuz our form hasn't
been the best in a very very very long
time so the last time I spoke is when we
lost to Arsenal 3-1 yeah yeah and this
was just before the international break
yes um and I was thinking okay we need
we need this this break has come at a
perfect time because we just need some
time to compose ourselves like we are
united but we're not playing like we're
United it's not making sense so our next
game after that 31 loss away was at home
against Brighton Brighton's not an easy
team whatever anyone wants to say
Brighton are probably one of the most
underrated teams going in the past
couple years and they're very good but
the way these men played against us at
home I just didn't understand why United
were playing the way they were playing
yeah yeah yeah long story short we lost
31 long story short we lost 31 that was
a few that was that was two weeks ago we
lost 31 I was like and the the peak
thing is we were losing 3-0 and we had
to bring on Hannibal Hannibal is like
once someone from like the reserves
youth team was waking his way up and he
he banged in a goal yeah and I was
thinking why does it have to resort to
this for us to do you know what I'm
saying why should it resort to this for
us to one at least have a goal have some
like involvement or encouragement or
some form of positive attitude to try
and do some cuz the rest of the week in
week out players apart from maybe two or
three were playing sluggish bro
absolutely sluggish and it's like this
is not the United I know yeah this is
not the United I know and this and I
know this is not what Eric ten hog wants
we just know we just know that I was
like cool charge at home charge and the
do you know the pest thing about
it prior to that game we hadn't lost the
game at home in like a season and a bit
oh last game we lost at home was against
Brighton but I was I was going to say
the first game of the season last season
Brighton 2-1 and they scored all three
goals because it was an own goal from
there
oh wow yeah I would never forget that
game and I would never forget the 4-nil
after that as well with brenford the
week after but anyway anyway
then we rolling into our first Champions
League game yeah yeah yeah we had Bayern
Munich away Alan Arena
Germany tough venue tough team tough
crowd and you're thinking let's see what
we got Champions League game we need to
reup and bounce back from the two 3-1
losses we've just had we didn't play the
best we lost 43 but to the thing is if
you score three goals out away in a
Champions League game you'd be thinking
I'm leaving with some I'm leaving with
some we just again they they were
winning 2-0 then we scored one 21 and as
soon as we scored they scored straight
away 3-1 and then we scored again and
they scored again it's like we couldn't
hold on to anything every time we scored
one we were like okay let's go and let's
go let's go and then the defense would
be left wide open the defense was just
it's the defense of the Midfield was so
poor over the past month it's clearly
hurt us so much and we had injuries and
we had um new people that had come on
that hadn't started yet so we finally
played another game yesterday but by the
time by the time this comes out it was
last week we played Crystal Palace in
the carabel cup our first game of that
cup competition and we played at home he
changed I think five or six players he
played all the youngsters well a lot of
the youngsters and he played um amrabat
who is a defensive midfielder who we
signed from Fiorentina who he's um we've
tried to start from the beginning of the
season but he's been injured but he only
started the other day he had his full
debut the other day and we played the
best football we've played all season
and we won 3-0 and that's that was like
it shouldn't have to take one yes we
changed players that we had people in
the Midfield that were back we had
different players and blah blah blah but
it shouldn't have to take this change up
of the team for us to play like we want
to play football like these men were
running like say we were two-nil down
and we needed to win the game back
that's how much that's how good we were
playing you know what I mean and it was
just so frustrating to see it was don't
get me wrong it was it was somewhat it
was bittersweet because I love the fact
we were playing well I love the fact
they were winning but I know for a fact
he's not going to play this squad on
Saturday because funny enough We've Got
Crystal Palace again in the PR League
this Saturday but we just played him in
the caraba cup and in Cup competitions
you tend to alter your squad just to
give everyone a
rotation but it's Food For Thought for
the actual starting 11 the regular
starting 11 to be like listen we need to
work off this momentum oh tell Li we won
against um we won against who did we win
one nil against um not Burnley that was
before this 3-0 Victory Burnley are
bottom of the league all right bottom of
the league they newly promoted um I
think they've got one point and we
struggled to beat
we were away I mean the goal was amazing
don't get me wrong but we struggled to
beat them and it was like wow wow this
is eye open in football so I'm happy we
we needed that 3-0 for the confidence
the morale the fans everything so I'm
I'm in a good place now but it's still
we're still average we're still so
average so I'm hoping by the time this
comes out it will be the match will be
done but I'm hoping Saturday against
Crystal Palace we do what we need to do
all right bet J I'm I'm I'm I keep
saying it bro I'm locking in I want to
be here with you even if I don't
commentate I want to be here with you
I'm going to jump on uhing yeah now TV
even oh yeah now TV I'm jump on and then
yeah I'm I'm I'm there okay I'm going to
jump on now TV pattern it watch it and
then I'm just going to wait cool I'm
going to wait I think it'll be juicy if
I just don't say anything and then I'm
going to wait and just hear I want to
hear um but anyway I'm going to have to
charge the episode there yeah yeah um
thank you guys for listening thank you
guys for watching we appreciate you uh
and as always love love love
[Music]
G